hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play [ __ ]
goddamnit hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to let's
play nether now it has been a while
since I played this game you guys have
been kind of demanding it from me and
understandably sobbing hello who is that
I saw something I saw a glowy glowy pink
thingy again tell me I didn't okay well
I thought I saw something there too now
I know to trust my senses in this game
and trust the things that I see in the
corner of my eye and I think I'm on a
server called like gravy raving lunatic
or crazy survivor or lone something so
I'm gonna go perfectly say go bonkers
crazy and I'm gonna shoot everyone that
I see on sight because I actually have
guns that are worth a damn and I know
that people are gonna want to kill me
for them because I I killed them for
them so anyway another note I did spawn
in a different location than I was
before so I do not have the safety of
the skyscraper that I was once in but
I'm back in the mode of scavenging for
supplies very simply oh it's back into
survival and it was very weird because I
opened up in the server and it was night
before it was like dead darkness and it
was kind of cool cuz I thought it was
gonna be like an atmospheric playthrough
where I was gonna be stalking people in
the middle of the night and trying to
survive all alone and scared like I was
before but now it's just kind of foggy I
don't know if this based in the UK or
not but um I'm okay that was a monster I
thought that was gonna be a player
monsters okay players not okay
players get dead monsters get left alone
I was gonna try to make that rhyme but
I'm not that clever okay so like I left
off before well before I was in a total
100% panic mode ready for anyone to stab
me in the back at any given time now I'm
still ready for people to stab me in the
back but I'm not necessarily freaking
out about I am ready
I have been hardened by all the time
that I've been playing with Bob and Wade
although I still haven't picked up Daisy
again I know that the dayz standalone
alpha and I have something cooking for
that then I think you guys are gonna
like but until that comes out it's just
gonna be me playing these and this is
the only one that have done solo so bear
with me as they take it very slow and
consciously okay so there's kind of a
suburban area over here
I think the stools are like a medium
populations forever I think there's 30
other people in the server so there's
bound to be people that Hammond Oh what
is that whoa whoa whoa what is that
thing that is a big thing
you still Pig what is he okay is he
guarding some goodies something nice
that I could use what that'll okay
that's not player that's a thing
something tells me they're going into
this area would be you don't you dig
with me Oh what the hell how'd you get
some clothes
come on there we go yeah got your [ __ ]
a good thing this gun has a silencer on
it because that means that I can get
kind of stealth kills without alerting
the entire operational area of my
location now I don't know how other
players will behave because I think it
was still kind of loud enough to be
heard but uh again I'm new by I don't
know how this game gets played where's
that big guy I know that big guy was
just around this corner where'd he go
hello hello now okay uh I guess what you
dick with me you really hear [ __ ] what
are you talking about oh there on the
corner don't tell me it's coming is it
going for another player or something oh
maybe another player killed the big
thing and that's why that's happening
maybe I could scope out a kill get his
stuff collect his giblets
another search is underway I still don't
know what that means but then again I
haven't really followed up on anything
about this so I don't know what whoa
whoa whoa that was another oh no that is
another new what there's some kind of
Church there st. Williams that's what
that sounds like I got to go one way or
another so the church seems to be
crawling with crew be doobies and that
way seems to be crawling with creepy
Tippy's I'm gonna go over this way but
not out in the open because that would
be safe zone secured oh that's what that
was I saw this earlier that this was
under attack
oh okay so that means the peeps went
down there now I don't think that you
can kill other players while you're in
the safe zone so it might behoove me to
go into a safe zone at some point in the
future if I wanted to rest and relax but
there's no guarantee that I would spawn
in what okay thought I saw something
in at that same location ergo would it
truly be a benefit to me I do need to
find more ammo though I need to find a
lot more ammo for my primary gun now I
do have some Ozzy ammo and also another
gun in my inventory that does not have a
silencer but I'm gonna prefer this one
for now I still kind of feel bad I don't
really feel bad at all but I still kind
of feel bad about that guy that I shot
for the guns that I have right now but I
don't actually feel bad at all I'm just
saying that for the benefit of you guys
listen I am still ready to kill anyone
in everyone keep your eyes peeled if you
see someone let me know in the comments
below like comment and favorite and
subscribe if you would I keep seeing
flashing lights and things out of the
corner of my eye I think the affected
people
nothing
that's not the same gas station that I
was that before I really want to go in
that church but at the same time I
really don't want to hey you know what
screw it you guys would want me to I
don't play for me I play for you so here
we go no one kill me no one shoot me
dead I'm gonna go in the gas station
first because I'm pretty sure actually
veau whoa oh whoa
hello baby take that anything else for
me you got any other goodies anything
else you'd like to give me I got to be
careful about my sprint meter because I
remember that sprint is a very simply
dabbling I don't even know English but
the very precarious resource I need to
spend very sparingly okay don't you jump
out of me you bastards what is that what
is that what is that what the hell is
that what the hell is that oh oh okay
okay I know that I called the other
things zom zoms incorrectly but what the
hell is that thing what do you want to
call that that looked very distinctly
like his arms arm and uh I don't know
what I'm gonna do about that okay I'm
gonna go up here scout it out first and
then I'm gonna go down I'm gonna play
this very strategic now I'm gonna go in
guns blazing screw all that noise okay I
still don't know what the hell that was
yeah no is a big thingy oh it's another
thing in a big Z maybe I should scout
out because going in guns blazing would
be a very bad idea okay let's do that
other thing let's see my crunchy poof
all right yep here we go hey Mike all
that didn't do much car give me more
thank you thank you very much
crunchy fence or whatever your name
would look good maybe another it's hard
to tell I don't know the spawn locations
for any of the goodies so I don't know
if I'm checking the right locations for
wherever I am going maybe right I may be
wrong
does anybody see anything over there
there anything worth pillaging I see a
lot of those weird zom zom alien mutant
thingies bear was there anything else
all right I'm gonna go in
what oh okay there's the thing there I'm
gonna go in but it's gonna be very
dangerous for me to go in but you guys
would want it you guys want to act huh
ah there we go you guys would want me to
go in so I'm gonna make you guys proud
I'm gonna do you guys justice what the
how did my house get so low wait are you
kidding me when in my house get that low
those are getting nine hundred last time
I look okay yeah that would have been a
terribly horrific idea if I'd have done
that with shovels shooting at me or
something
I take fall damage what didn't happen I
don't know what the hell that was lucky
to it damn it this is a terrible
terrible idea to want to go in here
isn't it come on let me down Jesus this
is uh this is a bad idea
hey this was a bad idea ah that's good
I'm going back up you're all you guys
new new thank you
hey would rather not have a new ass
coming after me
oh you know what screw you gree [ __ ]
were you at tamami Wow there we go yeah
you stay down all right that was a bad
idea I'm never going towards that church
again in fact I don't know why anyone
would buy new hoof out well move out of
the ground I'm level five [ __ ] let me
actually just there's a way to level up
how do I character ah oh yeah
there's something there he's nearby I
can smell him I can smell his pungent
aroma
ooh how about new your dad okay you
better stay dead damn it oh ma they ran
me out of ammo on my primary weapon need
to switch it out for this ax T there we
go
I know it doesn't have as much ammo but
at least has a scope on it so that I can
peg some people from across the map okay
so anyway I need uh cuz this game does
have some RPG elements which is a damn
shame considering that nothing is kept
over from before so a butter ski
headshot damage I think I don't I don't
know what I mean I don't know what the
benefit of that is but I'm gonna cross
into the tenement area over here see if
I can't find something nice I can be
nice for my skull
hmm I like the Aiden benefit that
anything useful is actually shiny it
doesn't happen in a lot of games and it
seems to be some like greater thing I
mean when do you have a game that has a
lot of detail and this game does have a
tremendous amount of detail put into it
it does go
then again I'm going into these doors
and I don't see anything I don't see
anything at all it doesn't I don't know
if that means that someone else came in
and pillaged it or if there just is
nothing in these because I've never
found anything in a supermarket area or
have I well this actually just kind of I
should shut up because apparently I'm a
giant idiot I just found crunchy beds
I'm gonna go
I got a bad feeling about this one but
then again I always had a bad feeling
when I played this game I actually said
to myself that I wasn't gonna play this
game so you guys should applaud your own
persistence that you guys got me to play
it again usually usually I do it I was
you know I play for you I love you guys
I love you guys to death of course I
played for you I think that's why I ran
into smitty werben jaegerman jensen and
that's where I killed him and his friend
I committed my first atrocity in this
messed up game oh well let's go back
let's see if I can find another smitty
werben jaegerman Johnson
I don't know if there's a pool there's
like a button for direct communication
there is for other games but I don't
know if there's a way to get my
microphone to represent my luxuriously
soft baritone voice into the ear holes
of others may or may not I don't know Oh
Smitty women jaegerman jensen come out
and play anybody anybody at all where am
I in the man okay I'm kind of headed
towards the safe zone area making my way
very slowly across the path still
haven't seen any other players which is
very strange because I did not pick a
low population server not that there
were I need to begin with though most of
the service did I saw at least dad bare
minimum 15 people in it and because the
playable area is not that large this is
the only area I mean it is kind of large
but I mean comparatively to something
else it's kind of a small sandbox to
play in
so ah crap new how about new how about
new can you stay over there I know that
I'm gonna run into another one
I'm just gonna name this episode new
that's all I've been doing this entire
time I've been playing all right okay
all right I know that okay never mind
those card or my mistake I was wrong it
seems like every place that is glowing
has more supplies in it so I'm hoping
that this place actually does okay one
of the problems that I had with this
game before was that Oh what is that
what is bro Mac's gonna turn me into a
super frat boy no that's wrong so very
wrong thank you back in my machine
pistol get anything in here
paramedics obliged I could use with some
more but apparently not there's some
dead bodies and rats but this bro max do
is there any sort of yeah is there any
store crafting system in this game I do
not know hello is someone there do not
know Hey
all right it could go on up into that
building but I know it's probably
fruitless okay I see some lights over
there I'm gonna head oh go that way okay
I'll stand on the open here all right
all right
we're okay we're all right not gonna die
today well probably gonna die today but
now I won't be to my fault
Roget whoa hello what is this over here
12-gauge do i I don't have a shotgun I
wish there was some better location of
the vendors than whatnot so that I could
try to help out and sell some stuff
I still don't know how the money system
really works in here Bailey whoa oh what
happened in here oh no that is a lot of
goopy gabber
and by goopy got her I mean blood
there's a lot of blood on the walls okay
anything else in the supermarket no ah I
see you over there
what are you Magnum ammo do I even have
a Magnum I don't think so okay I'm gonna
head I'm just gonna head to the shiny
lights it's all I'm gonna do because Joe
seemed to have the majority of supplies
then again is also seems to be where
other players would go but right at this
point I would like to run into other
players I really would hello fast Mart
sorry I raced only they're gonna kill me
in there will you get in to kill me I'm
gonna shoot me in the head want me full
already don't meet oh I'm dead wait this
doesn't even have an entrance what are
you doing
oh here we go give me some and give me
some give me something give me something
give me another player come on I'm bored
give me something to shoot give me that
big thing that was there before I'll
going to the church this time ain't
afraid I'm kind of
oh yeah I haven't seen anything so far
I'm really surprised I thought I thought
for sure I was gonna run into another
player eventually because I wasn't
exactly in hey what whoa what happened
here
what the hell what happened here why is
there just a gun I'll lay about this is
a trap someone gonna shoot me with
someone actually killed here uh okay I
can't even pick up those guns well I
think up this okay alright seemed
strange
maybe someone actually just dropped that
off maybe that was actually there I
don't know just seems weird that where
there would be gun and I don't know all
right so far so nothing really I thought
maybe not you know maybe it was just a
spawn location for items and I hit the
mother lode but I already had stuff so
no I still don't know what the Magnum
ammo is for cuz I'm pretty sure my
machine pistol uses nine-millimeter ammo
I'm gonna go in this and there's gonna
be the last place that check for now
no poll out of nothing okay this was a
waste of time all right so I am all out
of time for now I'm seriously perturbed
that I have not found anything but still
not bad considering I'm still alive and
I have my supplies so anyway I'm gonna
do one more after this one I don't have
a lot of time today it is I've been very
busy all day today so anyway thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video dangling by a string good
news
Wow
ah
I mean
ha
I guess not all of us are cut out to
make
go I'm gonna take this as a sign that